[Music]
one of gamescom's biggest trailers this
year was for an upcoming game title doe
kv
the trailer was fun stylish and flashy
and had pokemon in a big city vibes but
ultimately we still don't know all that
much about the game
so what the heck is doke v and why am i
so excited about a trailer that
ultimately didn't really show that much
gameplay to start doke v is being made
by pearl abyss this is a south korean
game developer whose credits consist of
black desert a sandbox mmorpg black
desert mobile the mobile version of this
and shadow arena a battle royale game
that was originally a mini game from
black desert pearl abyss actually has a
game scheduled to release by the end of
the year crimson desert which is an
action adventure rpg
and
so far that's it pearl abyss is a
relatively new company and dokey v is
completely different in style and tone
to their previous games according to
their announcement in 2019 dokey v was
originally said to be an mmo game
similar to black desert over development
this has changed and it's now a creature
collecting open world action adventure
according to the official website
they have stated there will be a
narrative focus to the game around
collecting dokey b so i have to imagine
this game will be somewhat similar to
final fantasy xv or assassin's creed and
how open the world will be but add in
pokemon style collecting and a more
action rpg oriented combat system
as seen in the trailer the game will
have strong creature collecting elements
where you'll be collecting dokey b
i'm sure it's no coincidence that this
sounds incredibly similar to the
legendary creatures from korean
mythology known as
doka bee or korean goblins in korean
folklore doke b are powerful spirits
that typically formed out of the
possession of inanimate objects they
also usually appear in dark creepy
corners at night or on a foggy rainy day
similar to many mythological beings do
kb can range from being kind to cruel
and are often mischievous they have
immense abilities and some are believed
to cause fires and disease while others
are helpful and can bring good fortune
and wealth and crops
all of that said i'm sure the dokeby of
korean mythology served as a very light
inspiration for the creatures of the
game
similar to the yokai of yokai watch
watching the trailer one of the things
that immediately stood out to me was all
of the different forms of travel that
you can use i spotted bicycling
skateboarding longboarding floating and
mid-air hopping via umbrella bouncy
balls llamas rollerblading rocket shoes
spider-man style webs that form in
mid-air jet skiing and mini cars and
while no one was actually on one as
someone who loves surfing drop in just
smack the lip
i really really hope surfing is a part
of the game as there was a brief scene
of characters by the beach with a bunch
of boards it's hard to tell as of yet
how much these modes of transportation
will truly make a difference for the
overall gameplay but it does make the
city seem like a playground the trailer
showed off various tricks the player
could do on many of these modes of
transportation and as the game is open
world in style maybe that means racking
up combos and tricks will actually be
some sort of mini game either way it
definitely looks like it will be a blast
to travel around
the actual gameplay itself shown
consisted of two elements the first of
these was an action game where it looks
like the pack on your character's back
can be used to pull out all sorts of
weapons for different kinds of attacks
these look to be creative toys that are
enhanced in size like a giant toy hammer
or a bouncy ball that can be used to
smash enemies we also saw water guns and
arrows meaning that you'll have a mix of
melee and ranged attacks all of the
actions shown included your character
needing to run and dodge from enemies
while it's unclear as of yet if there
will be rpg mechanics to the game the
combat itself definitely looks like a
fun take on the action genre according
to the team the action combat was
originally inspired by their own
previous games so taking a look at black
desert and the upcoming crimson desert
might be good indicators as to how the
game will play the other element we saw
comes from creature collecting unlike
pokemon and other similar turn-based
creature collecting rpgs in doke v
you'll actually be fighting alongside
the creatures you collect many of these
dokey b look like they not only have
unique attacks of their own but also
unique ways you can partner up with them
to strike against your foes it
definitely adds to the depth of the
combat and makes the game look even
stronger in my opinion
you may be unaware but the game's first
trailer was actually released in 2019
this particular trailer features the
character fighting off enemies with a
whole team of dokeby and there's brief
glimpses of the same thing in the newest
trailer which means that you'll be able
to assemble a whole fighting roster of
your dokey b and hopefully they'll have
unique cooperative attacks not only with
you as the player but with each other's
as well meaning you'd be able to put
together synergistic combinations if
that's the case
as far as how you collect these dokey b
i'm still not entirely sure there are
quests you activate to collect these
dokey b where you'll have to meet a
certain requirement first to me it
sounds similar to an rpg where you have
to own a special weapon and be level 20
then talking to the correct npc will
activate a quest to collect a special
weapon
except in this game it would be dokey b
according to the developers and i quote
as you progress through the story you
will meet and collect numerous dokeby
you will be able to activate the events
related to adokeb when you fulfill
special requirements then you can
collect the doki b as you progress
through a unique story hints related to
dokeby can be found not only in towns
but across the world discovering the
hints to encounter more doki b will also
be a fun aspect of the game
during this specific scene in the
trailer we see the character bust out a
vacuum and seemingly defeat an enemy in
a special way
if i were to guess this is actually the
character collecting another dokey b
so if that's the case the game will be
similar to pokemon in that you'll be
able to collect your monsters after
fighting them and weakening them
considering ghostbusters was one of the
influences on the game this does seem
pretty likely
although
that said considering the dokeb of
folklore come from inanimate objects who
knows maybe you actually find the dokey
b by exploring and finding the right
item as given to you within a quest
some other minor things are we see the
player's character at one point using
magic to change outfits it's not a big
thing but that along with all of the
other clothes in the game does showcase
that you'll be able to change your
clothes and likely collect new outfits
throughout the game the first trailer
showed a brief tease of a scuba diving
element so unless that was taken out of
the final product hopefully that means
you'll be able to explore underwater as
well
many aspects of korean culture were also
included in the game to give the game a
sense of familiarity as it drew from
real culture the beginning of the
trailer including my favorite brief
surfboard scene also shows your
character interacting with other normal
people this includes other kids playing
at a playground and someone fishing so
there will be some level of interaction
with people but how much is completely
unknown thus far
according to the lead producer this game
is about the main character going out to
collect okb with her friends the team
set out to make a family-friendly game
with the kids of the game actually
acting like kids they also wanted to
include comedy and fun interactions for
the player
personally a lot of the game reminded me
of when i first saw pokemon as a kid and
immediately connected with me hopefully
doke v will be as good as it looks as we
really haven't seen too much of how the
game will truly play
currently there's no release dates set
for doke v and it's set to come to pc
and console but which consoles are
unclear
are you looking forward to doke v or
cautiously optimistic about it let us
know in the comments below and hopefully
this shapes out to be something truly
special
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
[Music]